♪ Bone bone bone bone ♪
♪ Bone thugs and homeless ♪
♪ Bone bone bone ♪
♪ Said, brah,
that's what we gonna do ♪
♪ Where has everybody gone ♪
♪ Gone gone ♪
♪ Where have
all the people gone ♪
♪ How did we go broke ♪
♪ Think of all the lost hoes ♪
♪ Somehow we must've taken ♪
♪ A wrong turn at crossroads ♪
♪ Maybe we should change
our flow ♪
♪ But our flow is tight though ♪
♪ The harmony thing seems old ♪
♪ Something don't smell right,
yo ♪
♪ We smelling like hell
and not doing too well ♪
♪ And we live in a system
where nobody's giving away ♪
♪ Every day, every day
Poop in different alleyways ♪
♪ Homeless ♪
♪ bone ♪
♪ Homeless bone,
homeless bone, yeah ♪
♪ We piss and poop
in different alleyways ♪
♪ Can somebody spare
some change? ♪
♪ We spent all our money ♪
♪ can somebody - anybody -
spare some change ♪
♪ Listen to our tummies ♪
♪ Hey, man,
I miss my uncle Charles, y'all ♪
♪ He had some gall,
having a ball ♪
♪ Brother can't even
return my calls ♪
♪ Bone bone bone, bone, yeah ♪
♪ Bone thugs and homeless bone ♪
♪ We're so hungry...
We'll eat a bone ♪